From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Love, love, love, love, love.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。爱，爱，爱，爱，爱。
[MUSIC- "LOVE WALKED IN" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐——弗兰克·辛纳屈演唱的《爱走进来》]
What do we talk about when we talk about love? Well since the 13th century, this is what we talk about. This very moment.
当我们谈论爱的时候，我们在谈论什么？好吧，自13世纪以来，我们谈论的就是这个。就是这一刻。
Coup de foudre . Coup de foudre in French means the bolt of lightning, seeing someone and in an instant falling in love, love which happens in the moment of a flash.
一见钟情（Coup de foudre）。在法语中，这个词意为“闪电”，指看到某人并在瞬间坠入爱河，这种爱发生在电光火石的一刹那。
This is Richard Klein of Cornell University. In the 13th century, he says, Petrarch is walking by a fountain in the south of France, turns a corner, sees Laura. Petrarch looks into her eyes and in an instant his life is transformed. And he writes the first lyric love poems ever written.
这是康奈尔大学的理查德·克莱恩。他说，在13世纪，彼特拉克走在法国南部的一座喷泉旁，拐过一个弯，看到了劳拉。彼特拉克注视着她的眼睛，瞬间，他的人生被改变了。于是他写下了史上最早的抒情爱情诗。
He says, before this moment, one lives in a state of distraction. And things come and go, experiences, fragmentary, and chaotic. And all of a sudden, at the moment at which you encounter the eye of the other, it turns you into something else. You suddenly become-- your whole being becomes-- focused on that experience. And all you want to do once you've had that experience is to return over and over to that.
他说，在此刻之前，人生活在一种分散的状态中。各种事物来来去去，体验是零碎而混乱的。而突然之间，在你与对方眼神交汇的那一刻，它将你变成了另一个人。你突然变得……你的整个身心变得……专注于那种体验。而一旦拥有了这种体验，你所想做的就是一次又一次地回到那种感觉中。
30 years later in Florence, Dante goes through the same thing when he sees, at the top of a flight of stairs, Beatrice. He writes about it. And the idea of this moment, the bolt of lightning, gets repeated in literature, and song, and theater all through the Renaissance, up through the 19th century, and into the present day. Today, people who have not experienced that bolt of lightning in years, people who have been married for decades go to the movies, watch TV, to see it reenacted over and over. This is what we talk about when we talk about love.
30年后在佛罗伦萨，但丁在楼梯顶端看到贝阿特丽采时，经历了同样的事情。他对此进行了描写。关于这一刻——即闪电般的瞬间——的想法，在整个文艺复兴时期，一直到19世纪，直至今天，在文学、歌曲和戏剧中不断被重复。如今，那些多年未曾体验过那种闪电般瞬间的人，那些结婚几十年的夫妻，依然会去看电影、看电视，一遍又一遍地重温这种感觉。这就是当我们谈论爱时所谈论的内容。
In ancient Greek, the Greeks had two verbs for seeing, [? taorain ?] and [? drachain. ?] [? Taorain ?] is a way of seeing that we ordinarily understand as observation. [? Drachain ?] refers to the look that eyes can flash like lightning, like dragon breath, that not only illuminates the eye, but sends out a kind of fire that penetrates the eye of the other.
在古希腊语中，希腊人有两个表示“看”的动词：taorain和drachain。Taorain是我们通常理解为“观察”的那种观看方式。而drachain指的是眼神像闪电一样闪烁，像龙息一样，不仅照亮了眼睛，还射出一种能够穿透对方眼眸的火光。
And they Fhas specifically a separate word for that?
他们专门为那个瞬间造了一个词吗？
That's right. For the moment when eyes flash. And flash in a way which implies some kind of faithful encounter. I was struck looking at those tapes of Monica Lewinsky embracing the president on those rope lines. The thing that's most compelling about those images is the way her eyes flash at him. And one can't help but be struck by the light that's coming from those eyes.
没错。就是眼神交汇闪烁的那一刻。这种闪烁暗示着某种命中注定的邂逅。我看着莫妮卡·莱温斯基在警戒线旁拥抱总统的那些录像带时，感到非常震撼。这些影像中最引人注目的，是她的眼神闪烁着看向他时的样子。一个人不由得会被那双眼睛中透出的光芒所吸引。
OK, now here's the crazy thing. Everybody knows that that moment of initial rapture, that instant when your eyes meet and you're obsessed with the other person, thinking about them all the time-- everybody knows that that feeling doesn't usually last, that in some way it's just a dream, that over time it changes into something different. Here's the thing, even on the day that this romantic myth of love was born-- that day in the 13th century when Petrarch saw Laura-- even on that day, it was clear that it was just a myth. It was just a dream. Petrarch doesn't get the girl.
好了，疯狂的事情在于此。大家都知道，那种最初的狂喜时刻，那种眼神交汇、对某人魂牵梦绕、每时每刻都在想念对方的瞬间——大家都知道那种感觉通常不会持续太久，在某种程度上那只是一个梦，随着时间的推移，它会变成别的东西。关键在于，即使在爱的浪漫神话诞生的那天——彼特拉克见到劳拉的那一天——即便在那一天，也很清楚那只是一个神话。那只是一个梦。彼特拉克最终没能得到那个女孩。
No, the usual story is that the guy doesn't get the girl. But maybe you never get the girl. Maybe that's the sort of condition of falling in love. It always remains something sort of inaccessible. At the moment that desire is fulfilled, desire dies. Psychologists have estimated that you can only stick in love for 18 months. That's the limit. After that, it becomes something else, becomes admiration, respect, affection, and so forth. But the--
不，通常的故事是男孩没有得到女孩。但也许你永远得不到那个女孩。也许这就是坠入爱河的一种状态。它总是保持着某种无法触及的东西。当欲望得到满足的那一刻，欲望也就随之消亡了。心理学家估计，坠入爱河的状态只能维持18个月。那是极限。在那之后，它会变成别的东西，变成钦佩、尊重、亲情等等。但是……
The dream of it dissolves and becomes something else.
那种梦幻感溶解了，变成了别的东西。
Something else.
变成了别的东西。
I wonder if you would be saying this and explaining this in these terms if you, yourself, were falling in love right now.
我很好奇，如果你自己现在正坠入爱河，你还会以这样的方式和理论来解释它吗？
Well, as a matter of fact, I think I am.
事实上，我想我正是如此。
Well then, you're going to get in trouble when this goes on the radio, aren't you?
那么，当这期节目播出时，你会有麻烦的，不是吗？
Oh, I'm going to be in so much trouble. You have no idea.
哦，我会惹上大麻烦的。你根本无法想象。
So you're falling in love right now and you're holding to the idea that this is an illusion and a sort of illusory experience?
所以你现在正坠入爱河，却坚持认为这是一种错觉和虚幻的体验？
Oh, but all I want is more, more illusion, more illusion.
哦，但我想要的只是更多，更多的幻觉，更多的幻觉。
So today, beloved listener, we come to you with a mission. Since stories of love-- in fact, our whole idea of love-- these things are usually about how it feels during those first moments of falling in love. Today, for Valentine's Day, as a public service, we make an attempt to understand another side of what love means. We bring you stories of couples that all take place decades after the moment their eyes meet.
所以今天，亲爱的听众，我们带着一个使命而来。因为爱情故事——事实上，我们对爱的整体观念——通常都是关于坠入爱河最初那几刻的感觉。今天，作为情人节的一项公共服务，我们试图理解爱情含义的另一面。我们为你带来那些发生在眼神交汇几十年后的伴侣的故事。
Act One, "Before and After," the beginning of love as viewed from a moment near its ending. Act Two, "The Over-Protective Kind," in which a husband worries about his wife's safety on a very dangerous undertaking she's about to go on, to a beach resort. Act Three, "Istanbul," Ian Brown talks about what it means to stay monogamous. Stay with us.
第一幕，“之前与之后”，从临近终点的时刻回望爱情的开端。第二幕，“过度保护型”，一位丈夫担心妻子即将去一个非常危险的地方——海滨度假村——的安危。第三幕，“伊斯坦布尔”，伊恩·布朗谈论保持一夫一妻制意味着什么。请继续收听。
Act One. "Before and after." Well as a kid growing up in the east coast in the 1970s, for me, the most romantic songs in the world-- and this is kind of a corny thing to admit now years later, with retrospect-- the most romantic songs in the world were Bruce Springsteen's. Songs about falling in love in rundown beach towns on the Jersey shore, songs about hitting the road together to who knows where. But once Bruce hit a certain age, he stopped writing songs about that moment when lightning flashes between people, when their eyes meet. And he wrote a series of songs where basically every song takes place long after the couple fell out of love. And the narrator, or the singer in these songs, is remembering that exhilarating moment of falling in love and then describing the moment he's in now, the drudgery of his marriage now. And he's laying these two moments side by side, trying to make sense of how one of them has any connection in the world to the other, how one of them led to the other. Well, this next story is something like that. It's by Richard Bausch.
第一幕，“之前与之后”。好吧，作为一个在70年代东海岸长大的孩子，对我来说，世界上最浪漫的歌曲——现在回想起来承认这一点有点老土——世界上最浪漫的歌曲是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的。那些关于在新泽西海岸破败的海滨小镇坠入爱河的歌，那些关于一起开车去往未知之地的歌。但当布鲁斯到了某个年纪，他不再写那些关于人们眼神交汇、闪电划过瞬间的歌曲了。他写了一系列歌曲，基本每一首歌都发生在伴侣爱情消逝很久之后。歌中的叙述者或歌手在回忆当年坠入爱河那激动人心的时刻，然后描述他现在所处的时刻，也就是他婚姻中的苦差事。他将这两个瞬间并排摆在一起，试图弄明白它们之间到底有什么关联，其中一个是如何导致了另一个的。好吧，接下来的这个故事就是这样的。作者是理查德·鲍什。
It's exactly 20 minutes to midnight, on this, the eve of my 70th birthday. And I've decided to address you, for a change, in writing, odd as that might seem. I'm perfectly aware of how you're going to take the fact that I'm doing this at all, so late at night with everybody due to arrive tomorrow and the house still unready. I haven't spent almost five decades with you without learning a few things about you that I can predict and describe with some accuracy. Though I admit that, as you put it, lately we've been more like strangers than husband and wife.
距离午夜正好20分钟，在这一天，也就是我70岁生日的前夜。我决定破例写信给你，尽管这看起来很奇怪。我完全清楚你会如何看待我深夜做这件事，明天大家都要到了，房子还没收拾好。和你一起生活了近五十年，我已学会了一些关于你的、能够准确预测和描述的事情。尽管我承认，正如你所说，最近我们比起夫妻更像是陌生人。
Well, so if we are like strangers, perhaps there are some things I can tell you that you won't have already figured out about the way I feel. Tonight we had another one of those long, silent evenings after an argument. Remember? Over pepper. We had been bickering all day really, but at dinner I put paper on my potatoes and you said that about how I shouldn't have pepper because it always upsets my stomach. I'm bothered to remark that I used to eat chili peppers for breakfast. And if I wanted to put plain, old, ordinary black pepper on my potatoes-- as I had been doing for more than 60 years-- that was my privilege.
好吧，既然我们像陌生人，也许有些关于我的感受，你还没能察觉出来。今晚在争吵后，我们又度过了一个漫长的沉默夜晚。记得吗？关于胡椒。其实我们整天都在争吵，但在晚餐时，我在土豆上撒了胡椒，你说我不该吃胡椒，因为它总让我的胃不舒服。我感到烦躁，于是反驳说我以前早餐都吃辣椒。如果我想在土豆上撒点普通、老派的黑胡椒——就像我过去60年来所做的那样——那是我的特权。
Writing this now, it sounds far more testy than I meant it. But that isn't really the point. In any case, you chose to overlook my tone. You simply said, "John, you were up all night the last time you had pepper with your dinner."
现在写下来，听起来比我的本意要刻薄得多。但这并不是重点。无论如何，你选择了忽略我的语气。你只是说：“约翰，上次你晚餐吃了胡椒后，一整晚都没睡。”
I said, "I was up all night because I ate green peppers, not black pepper but green peppers."
我说：“我一整晚没睡是因为我吃了青椒，不是黑胡椒，是青椒。”
"A pepper is a pepper. Isn't it?" You said. And then I started in on you. I got-- as you call it-- legal with you, pointing out that green peppers are not black pepper. And from there we moved on to an evening of mutual disregard for each other that ended with your decision to go to bed early. The grandchildren will make you tired and there's still the house to do. You had every reason to want to get some rest. And yet, I felt that you were also making a point of getting yourself out of proximity with me, leaving me to my displeasure with another ridiculous argument settling between us like a fog.
“胡椒就是胡椒，不是吗？”你说。然后我就开始针对你了。我变得——正如你所说的——和你讲起理来，指出青椒不是黑胡椒。从那以后，我们就陷入了互相漠视的夜晚，最终以你决定早早上床睡觉而告终。孙辈们会让你累坏，房子还有活儿要做。你有充分的理由想休息。然而，我却觉得你也是故意要避开我，留我独自面对我们之间像雾一样笼罩的那些愚蠢争吵带来的不快。
So after you went to bed, I got out the whiskey and started pouring drinks. And I had every intention of putting myself into a stupor. It was also my birthday, after all, and-- forgive this, it's the way I felt at the time-- you had nagged me into an argument and then gone off to bed. The day had ended as so many of our days end now. And I felt, well, entitled. I had a few drinks without any appreciable effect, though you might well see this letter as firm evidence to the contrary.
所以你上床后，我拿出了威士忌开始倒酒。我当时完全打算把自己灌醉。毕竟也是我的生日，而且——请原谅我这么说，这确实是我当时的感受——是你唠叨着挑起争端然后上床睡觉的。这一天就像我们现在许多日子一样结束了。我感觉，好吧，我有权利这样做。我喝了几杯，没有任何明显的影响，尽管你很可能会把这封信看作是事实的有力反证。
And then I decided to do something to shake you up. I would leave. I'd make a lot of noise going out the door. I'd take a walk around the neighborhood and make you wonder where I could be. Perhaps I'd go check into a motel for the night. The thought even crossed my mind that I might leave you all together. I admit that I entertained the thought, Marie. I saw our life together now as the day to day round of petty quarreling and tension that it's mostly been over the past couple of years or so. And I wanted out as sincerely as I ever wanted out of anything.
然后我决定做点什么让你震惊一下。我要离开。出门时我要弄出很大的动静。我要在附近散步，让你猜我在哪儿。也许我会去汽车旅馆开个房住一晚。我甚至想过干脆离开你。我承认我确实有过这样的想法，玛丽。我们的生活现在对我来说，就是过去两年多以来大部分时间里那种琐碎争吵和紧张的日常循环。我真心地想从中解脱，就像我曾渴望摆脱任何事情一样。
And I got up from my seat in front of the television and walked back down the hall to the entrance of our room to look at you. I suppose I hoped you'd still be awake so I could tell you of this momentous decision I felt I'd reached. And maybe you were awake. One of our oldest areas of contention being the noise I make, the feather thin membrane of your sleep that I am always disturbing with my restlessness in the nights.
我从电视机前的座位上站起来，顺着走廊走到我们房间的入口看你。我想我当时是希望你还没睡，这样我就可以告诉你这个我感到自己已经做出的重大决定。也许你确实醒着。我们争执最久的问题之一就是我制造的噪音，你那脆弱如羽毛般的睡眠总是被我在夜间的辗转反侧所打扰。
All right, assuming you were asleep and don't know that I stood in the doorway of our room, I will say that I stood there for perhaps five minutes looking at you in the half dark, the shape of your body under the blanket. You really did look like one of the girls when they were little and I used to stand in the doorway of their rooms. Your illness last year made you so small again. And as I said, I thought I had decided to leave you for your peace as well as mine.
好吧，假设你睡着了，不知道我曾在我们的房门口站过，我会说我可能在那里站了五分钟，在半暗的光线中看着你，看着毛毯下你的身体轮廓。你看起来确实像女孩们小时候的样子，我曾站在她们房门口那样看着她们。去年的那场病让你又变得那么瘦小。正如我所说，我想我已经决定离开你，为了你的安宁，也为了我的。
I know you have gone to sleep crying, Marie. I know you felt sorry about things and wished we could find some way to stop irritating each other so much. Well, of course, I didn't go anywhere. I came back to this room and drank more of the whiskey and watched television. It was like all the other nights. The shows came on and ended and the whiskey began to wear off. There was a little rain shower. I had a moment of the shock of knowing I was 70.
我知道你是哭着入睡的，玛丽。我知道你对发生的事情感到遗憾，希望我们能找到某种方法停止这样互相折磨。好吧，当然，我哪儿也没去。我回到这间屋子，喝了更多的威士忌，看电视。就像其他所有的夜晚一样。节目开始了又结束，威士忌的酒劲也开始消退。下了一场小雨。我有一瞬间感到震惊，意识到自己已经70岁了。
After the rain ended, I did go outside for a few minutes. I stood on the sidewalk and looked at the house. The kids, with their kids, were on the road somewhere between their homes and here. I walked up to the end of the block and back and a pleasant breeze blew and shook the drops out of the trees. My stomach was bothering me some and maybe it was the pepper I'd put on my potatoes. It could just as well have been the whiskey.
雨停后，我确实出门走了几分钟。我站在人行道上看着房子。孩子们带着孙辈们正在从他们家到这里的路上。我走到街区尽头又折回来，一阵宜人的微风吹过，把树上的雨滴抖落下来。我的胃有些不舒服，也许是我在土豆上撒的胡椒，也有可能是威士忌。
Anyway, as I came back to the house, I began to have an eerie feeling that I had reached the last night of my life. There was this small discomfort in my stomach and no other physical pang or pain. And I'm used to the small ills and side effects of my ways of eating and drinking. Yet I felt a sense of the end of things more strongly than I can describe. When I stood in the entrance of our room and looked at you again, wondering if I would make it through to the morning, I suddenly found myself trying to think what I would say to you if, indeed, this were the last time I would ever be able to speak to you. And I began to know I would write you this letter.
无论如何，当我回到家时，我开始有一种诡异的感觉，觉得这可能是我的最后一晚了。胃里有那种小小的难受，除此之外没有其他的身体剧痛。我已经习惯了我的饮食习惯带来的小毛病和副作用。然而，我感到一种强烈的终结感，无法用言语形容。当我站在房间入口再次看着你，怀疑自己是否能撑到明天早晨时，我突然试图去想，如果这真的是我最后一次能和你说话，我会对你说什么。于是我开始知道，我会写这封信给你。
At least words in a letter aren't blurred by tone of voice, by the old, aggravating sound of me talking to you. I began with this and with the idea that, after months of thinking about it, I would at last try to say something to you that wasn't colored by our disaffection. What I have to tell you must be explained in a rather round about way.
至少信里的文字不会被说话的语气、不会被我跟你说话时那种恼人的陈词滥调所模糊。我以此为开端，想着在考虑了几个月后，我终于要尝试对你说一些没有被我们那些不和所渲染的话。我必须以一种相当婉转的方式来解释我想要告诉你的事情。
I've been thinking about my cousin, Louise, and her husband. When he died and she stayed with us last summer, something brought back to me what is really only the memory of a moment. Yet it reached me, that moment, across more than 50 years.
我一直在想我的堂姐路易丝和她的丈夫。当他去世，路易丝去年夏天和我们住在一起时，某件事让我回想起那仅仅是一个瞬间的记忆。然而，那个瞬间跨越了50多年，深深触动了我。
As you know, Louise is nine years older than I and more like an older sister than a cousin. I must have told you, at one time or another, that I spent some weeks with her back in 1933, when she was first married. The memory I'm talking about comes from that time. And what I have decided I have to tell you comes from that memory. Father had been dead four years. We were all used to the fact that times were hard and that there was no man in the house, though I suppose I filled that role in some titular way.
如你所知，路易丝比我大九岁，比起堂姐，她更像我的亲姐姐。我一定在某个时候告诉过你，1933年她刚结婚时，我曾在她那里住过几周。我说的那个记忆就来自那个时期。我决定告诉你的事情，也正是源于那段记忆。父亲已经去世四年了。我们都习惯了生活艰难、家里没有男人的事实，尽管我想我在名义上确实扮演了那个角色。
In any case, when mother became ill, there was the problem of us, her children. Though I was the oldest, I wasn't old enough to stay in the house alone or to nurse her either. My grandfather came up with a solution-- and everybody went along with it-- that I would go to Louise's for a time and the two girls would go to stay with grandfather.
无论如何，当母亲生病时，我们这些孩子就成了问题。虽然我是最大的，但我还不够大，不能独自留在家里，也不能照顾她。我祖父想出了一个办法——大家都同意了——我暂时去路易丝家住一段时间，两个女孩去和祖父住。
So we closed up the house and I got on a train to Virginia. I was a few weeks shy of 14 years old. I remember that I was not able to believe that anything truly bad would come of mother's pleurisy and was consequently glad of the opportunity it afforded me to travel the 100 miles south to Charlottesville, where cousin Louise had moved with her new husband only a month earlier, after her wedding.
于是我们锁上了房子，我坐火车去了弗吉尼亚。我离14岁还差几周。我记得当时我无法相信母亲的胸膜炎会带来什么真正糟糕的后果，因此我很庆幸有机会去100英里外的夏洛茨维尔，那是堂姐路易丝在婚礼后一个月刚刚搬去的地方。
Because we traveled so much at the beginning, you never got to really know Charles when he was young. In 1933 he was a very tall, imposing fellow with bright red hair and a graceful way of moving that always made me think of athletics and contests of skill. He had worked at the Navy Yard in Washington and had been laid off in the first months of Roosevelt's New Deal. Louise was teaching in a day school in Charlottesville so they could make ends meet. And Charles was spending most of his time looking for work and fixing up the house.
因为我们在开始的时候旅行太多，你从来没真正了解过年轻时的查尔斯。1933年，他是一个非常高大、威严的家伙，有着红亮的头发和一种优雅的举止，总让我想起运动和竞技。他在华盛顿海军工厂工作，在罗斯福新政的头几个月被裁员了。路易丝在夏洛茨维尔的一所走读学校教书，好让我们维持生计。查尔斯大部分时间都在找工作和修缮房子。
I had only met Charles once or twice before the wedding, but already I admired him and wanted to emulate him. The prospect of spending time in his house, or perhaps going fishing with him in the small streams of central Virginia, was all I thought about on the way down. And I remember that we did go fishing one weekend, that I wound up spending a lot of time with Charles, helping to paint the house and to run water lines under it for indoor plumbing.
在婚礼前我只见过查尔斯一两次，但我已经很钦佩他并想效仿他。在去那里的路上，我脑子里想的尽是在他家待着，或者和他一起在弗吉尼亚中部的小溪里钓鱼。我记得我们确实去钓过一次鱼，我最终花了很多时间和查尔斯在一起，帮着粉刷房子，在底下铺设室内管道。
Oh, I had time with Louise too, listening to her read from the books she wanted me to be interested in, walking with her around Charlottesville in the evenings, and looking at the city as it was then, or sitting on her small porch and talking about the family, mother's stubborn illness, the children Louise saw every day at school. But what I want to tell you has to do with the very first day I was there.
哦，我和路易丝也有独处的时间，听她读她想让我感兴趣的书，晚上陪她在夏洛茨维尔散步，看那时候的城市，或者坐在她的小门廊上谈论家庭、母亲顽固的病情、路易丝每天在学校见到的孩子们。但我想告诉你的事与我到那里的第一天有关。
I know you think I use far too much energy thinking about and pining away for the past. And I therefore know that I'm taking a risk by talking about this ancient history and by trying to make you see it. But this all has to do with you and me, my dear, and our late inability to find ourselves in the same room together without bitterness and pain. That summer, 1933, was unusually warm in Virginia. And the heat, along with my impatience to arrive, made the train almost unbearable. I think it was just past noon when it pulled into the station in Charlottesville, with me hanging out one of the windows looking for Louise or Charles. It was Charles who had come to meet me. He stood in a crisp-looking seersucker suit with a straw boater cocked at just the angle you'd expect a young, newly married man to wear a straw boater, even in the middle of economic disaster.
我知道你认为我把太多的精力花在思考和怀念过去上。因此我知道我在冒险谈论这段古老的历史，并试图让你去理解它。但这完全与你我有关，我亲爱的，与我们最近无法在同一个房间里相处而没有苦涩和痛苦有关。1933年的那个夏天，弗吉尼亚异常温暖。酷热加上我迫不及待抵达的心情，让火车几乎变得难以忍受。我想火车抵达夏洛茨维尔车站时刚过中午，我把头伸出窗外寻找路易丝或查尔斯。是查尔斯来接我的。他穿着一身干练的泡泡纱西装，戴着一顶草帽，帽檐的角度正如你所期望的一个年轻的新婚男子在经济灾难中佩戴的那样。
I waved at him and he waved back and I might have jumped out the window if the train had slowed even a little more than it had before it stopped in the shade of platform. I made my way out, carrying the cloth bag my grandfather had given me for the trip. Mother had said, through her room, that I looked like a carpetbagger. And when I stepped down to shake hands with Charles, I noticed that what I thought was a new suit was tattered at the ends of the sleeves.
我向他招手，他也招手回应，如果火车在站台树荫下停稳前再慢一点点，我可能就跳出窗外了。我提着祖父给我准备的布袋下了车。母亲曾说我看起来像个地毯包客。当我走下车与查尔斯握手时，我注意到那件我以为是新的西装，袖口已经磨损了。
"Well," he said, "Young John." I smiled at him and I was perceptive enough to see that his cheerfulness was not entirely effortless. He was a man out of work, after all. And so, in spite of himself, there was worry in his face, the slightest shadow in an otherwise glad and proud countenance.
“好吧，”他说，“小约翰。”我对他笑了笑，我足够敏锐地察觉到他的开朗并非毫不费力。毕竟，他是一个失业的人。所以，尽管他极力掩饰，他的脸上还是带着忧虑，在他那本该愉悦而自豪的脸上投下了一道极淡的阴影。
We walked through the station to the street and on up the steep hill to the house, which was a small, clapboard structure, a cottage really, with a porch at the end of the short sidewalk lined with flowers. They were marigolds, I think. And here was Louise coming out of the house, her arms already stretched wide to embrace me. "Lord," she said, "I swear you've grown since the wedding, John."
我们穿过车站来到街上，走上陡峭的山坡来到房子，那是一座小的木板结构，其实是个小屋，短人行道尽头的门廊旁种满了花。我想是万寿菊。路易丝从屋里出来，双臂张开迎向我。“天哪，”她说，“我发誓你从婚礼到现在又长高了，约翰。”
Charles took my bag and went inside. "Let me look at you, young man," Louise said. I stood for inspection. And as she looked me over, I saw that her hair was pulled back, that a few strands of it had come loose, that it was brilliantly auburn in the sun. I suppose I was a little in love with her. She was grown and married now. She was a part of what seemed a great mystery to me, even as I was about to enter it. And of course, you remember how that feels, Marie, when one is on the verge of things, nearly adult, nearly old enough to fall in love.
查尔斯接过我的行李走进屋里。“让我好好看看你，小伙子，”路易丝说。我站着接受检视。当她打量我时，我看到她的头发向后梳着，几缕发丝散落下来，在阳光下呈现出灿烂的赤褐色。我想我当时有点爱上她了。她现在已经长大了，也结婚了。她成了我心中一个巨大谜团的一部分，尽管我正要走进那个谜团。当然，你记得那种感觉，玛丽，当一个人站在事物的边缘，几乎成年，几乎大到可以坠入爱河时。
I looked at Louise's happy, flushed face and felt a deep ache as she ushered me into her house. I wanted so to be older. Inside, Charles had poured lemonade for us and was sitting in the easy chair by the fireplace, already sipping his. Louise wanted to show me the house and the backyard, which she had tilled and turned into a small vegetable garden. But she must have sensed how thirsty I was and so she asked me to sit down and have a cool drink before she showed me the upstairs.
我看着路易丝那张幸福、红润的脸，当她带我进屋时，感到一种深深的隐痛。我多么希望自己能快点长大。屋里，查尔斯已经为我们倒了柠檬水，坐在壁炉旁的安乐椅上，正在喝着。路易丝想带我参观房子和后院，她在那耕种并弄成了一个小菜园。但她一定感觉到我是多么口渴，所以她让我坐下喝杯冷饮，然后再带我去看楼上。
Now of course, looking back on it, I remember that those rooms she was so anxious to show me were meager indeed. They were not much bigger than closets really, and the paint was faded and dull. The furniture she'd arranged so artfully was coming apart. The pictures she'd put on the walls were prints she'd cut out, magazine covers mostly. And the curtains over the windows were the same ones that hung in her childhood bedroom for 20 years.
当然，回过头来看，我记得她急切想让我参观的那些房间确实很寒碜。它们比衣柜大不了多少，油漆褪色而暗淡。她精心布置的家具正在散架。墙上的画是她剪下来的印刷品，大部分是杂志封面。窗帘还是她童年卧室里挂了20年的那一套。
"Recognize these?" she said with a deprecating smile. Of course, the quality of her pride had nothing to do with the fineness, or lack of it, in these things, but in the fact that they belonged to her and that she was a married lady in her own house.
“认出这些了吗？”她带着自嘲的微笑说。当然，她自豪的本质与这些东西的精致与否无关，而在于它们属于她，她是自己家里的女主人的事实。
On this day in July, in 1933, she and Charles were waiting for the delivery of a fan they had scrounged enough money to buy from Sears, through the catalog. There were things they would rather have been doing, especially in this heat, and especially with me there. Monticello wasn't far away. The university was within walking distance. And without too much expense, one could ride a taxi to one of the lakes nearby. They had hoped that the fan would arrive before I did, but since it hadn't-- and since neither Louise nor Charles was willing to leave the other alone while traipsing off with me that day-- there wasn't anything to do but wait around for it.
在1933年7月的这一天，她和查尔斯正在等一台风扇送货，他们从西尔斯目录上凑够了钱买的。他们本来有更想做的事情，特别是在这种高温下，尤其是我还在场的情况下。蒙蒂塞洛离这不远。大学在步行距离内。稍微花点钱，就可以乘出租车到附近的湖边。他们本希望风扇能在我到达之前送到，但既然没有——而且路易丝和查尔斯都不愿意让对方独自留在家，而带我出去玩——就没别的事可做，只能待着等它了。
Louise had opened the windows and shut the shades and we sat in her small living room and drank the lemonade, fanning ourselves with folded parts of Charles' morning newspaper. From time to time, an anemic breath of air would move the shades slightly. But everything grew still again. Louise sat on the arm of Charles's chair and I sat on the sofa. We talked about pleurisy and, I think, about the fact that Thomas Jefferson had invented the dumbwaiter, how the plumbing at Monticello was at least a century ahead of its time.
路易丝打开窗户拉上窗帘，我们坐在她狭小的客厅里喝着柠檬水，用折叠好的查尔斯早晨的报纸扇风。偶尔，一丝贫血般的微风会轻轻吹动窗帘。但一切又归于沉寂。路易丝坐在查尔斯的椅扶手上，我坐在沙发上。我们谈论着胸膜炎，我想还谈到了托马斯·杰斐逊发明了送菜电梯，谈到了蒙蒂塞洛的管道系统领先于时代至少一个世纪。
Charles remarked that it was the spirit of invention that would make a man's career in these days. "That's what I'm aiming for, to be inventive in a job, no matter what it winds up being."
查尔斯评论说，正是这种发明精神在这些日子里将成就一个人的事业。“这就是我的目标，要在工作中具有创造力，无论那最终会是什么工作。”
When the lemonade ran out, Louise got up and went into the kitchen to make some more. Charles and I talked about taking a weekend to go fishing. He leaned back in his chair and put his hands behind his head looking satisfied. In the kitchen, Louise was chipping ice for our glasses. And she began singing something low for her own pleasure, a barely audible lilting. And Charles and I sat listening. It occurred to me that I was very happy. I had the sense that soon I would be embarked on my own life, as Charles was. And that an attractive woman like Louise would be there with me.
当柠檬水喝完时，路易丝起身去厨房再做一些。查尔斯和我谈到了找个周末去钓鱼。他靠在椅背上，双手抱头，看起来很满足。在厨房里，路易丝在为我们的杯子凿冰。她开始轻声哼唱，那是为了自娱自乐，声音低到几乎听不见。我和查尔斯坐着倾听。我突然觉得我很幸福。我有一种感觉，很快我也将踏上自己的人生之旅，就像查尔斯那样。而像路易丝这样有吸引力的女人也会在我身边。
Charles yawned and said, "God, listen to that. Doesn't Louise have the loveliest voice?"
查尔斯打了个哈欠说：“天哪，听听那个。路易丝的声音难道不迷人吗？”
And that's all I have from that day. I don't even know if the fan arrived later. And I have no clear memory of how we spent the rest of the afternoon and evening. I remember Louise singing a song, her husband leaning back in his chair, folding his hands behind his head, expressing his pleasure in his young wife's voice. I remember that I felt quite extraordinarily content just then. And that's all I remember.
那天我所记得的只有这些了。我甚至不知道风扇后来有没有送到。对于那天下午和晚上的余下时间，我没有清晰的记忆。我记得路易丝唱了一首歌，她的丈夫靠在椅子上，双手抱在脑后，表达着他对年轻妻子歌声的愉悦。我记得那一刻我感到极其满足。这就是我记得的全部了。
But there are, of course, the things we both know. We know they moved to Colorado to be near Charles' parents. We know they never had any children. We know that Charles fell down a shaft at a construction site in the fall of 1957 and was hurt so badly that he never walked again. And I know that when she came to stay with us last summer, she told me she'd learned to hate him, and not for what she'd had to help him do all those years. No, it started earlier and was deeper than that. She hadn't minded the care of him-- the washing and feeding and all the numberless small tasks she had to perform each and every day, all day. She hadn't minded this. In fact, she thought there was something in her makeup that liked being needed so completely. The trouble was simply that whatever she had once loved in him she had stopped loving. And for many, many years before he died, she'd felt only suffocation when he was near enough to touch her, only irritation and anxiety when he spoke.
但当然，有些事情我们俩都知道。我们知道他们后来搬到了科罗拉多，为了靠近查尔斯的父母。我们知道他们从未有过孩子。我们知道查尔斯在1957年秋天在建筑工地掉进了一个竖井，伤得很重，从此再没能站起来。我也知道，当她去年夏天来我家住时，她告诉我她已经学会了恨他，不是因为这么多年她不得不帮他做的一切。不，这开始得更早，也更深刻。她并不介意照顾他——洗漱、喂饭以及她每一天、整天必须执行的数不清的小任务。她并不介意这些。事实上，她认为自己骨子里有一种喜欢被彻底需要的成分。麻烦仅仅在于，她曾经爱过他的某种东西，她已经不再爱了。在他去世前的许多许多年里，当他靠近到触手可及的地方时，她只感到窒息；当他说话时，她只感到烦躁和焦虑。
She said all this and then looked at me, her cousin, who had been fortunate enough to have children and to be in love over time and said, "John, how have you and Marie managed it?" And what I wanted to tell you has to do with this fact. That while you and I had had one of our whispering arguments only moments before, I felt quite certain of the simple truth of the matter, which is that-- whatever our complications-- we have managed to be in love over time. "Louise," I said.
她说完了这些，看着我这个有幸有了孩子并相爱了一生的堂弟，说：“约翰，你和玛丽是怎么做到这一切的？”我想告诉你的事与这个事实有关。虽然就在几分钟前我们还刚进行了一场低声的争吵，但我感到完全确定事情的简单真理，那就是——无论我们之间有多少纠葛——我们终究设法在岁月流逝中保持着爱。“路易丝，”我说。
"People start out with such high hopes," she said, as if I wasn't there. She looked at me. "Don't they?"
“人们开始时总是抱着那么高的期望，”她说，好像我不在场一样。她看着我。“不是吗？”
"Yes," I said.
“是的，”我说。
She seemed to consider this a moment and she said, "I wonder how it happens."
她似乎考虑了一会儿，然后说：“我在想这是怎么发生的。”
I said, "You ought to get some rest," or something equally pointless and admonitory. As she moved away from me, I had an image of Charles standing on the station platform in Charlottesville that summer, the straw boater set at its cocky angle. It was an image I would see most of the rest of that night, and on many another night since.
我说：“你该休息一下了，”或者说了些同样毫无意义的劝诫话。当她离开我时，我脑海中浮现出那个夏天查尔斯站在夏洛茨维尔车站站台上的样子，那顶草帽歪戴着，角度很傲慢。那是我那天晚上剩下的时间里，以及此后许多夜晚里经常看到的画面。
I can almost hear your voice as you point out that, once again, I've managed to dwell too long in a memory of something that's passed and gone. The difference is that I'm not grieving over the past now. I am merely reporting a memory so that you might understand what I'm about to say to you.
我几乎可以听到你的声音在指出，我又一次沉溺于对往事的怀念中太久了。不同之处在于，我现在不是在为过去感到悲伤。我只是在陈述一段记忆，这样你或许能理解我接下来要对你说的话。
The fact is, we aren't the people we were even then, just a year ago. I know that as I know things have been slowly eroding between us for a very long time. We are a little tired of each other. And there are annoyances and old scars that won't be obliterated with a letter, even a long one written in the middle of the night in desperate sincerity, under the influence-- admittedly-- of a considerable portion of bourbon whisky, but nevertheless, with the best intention and hope that you may know how, over the course of this night, I came to the end of needing an explanation for our difficulty.
事实上，我们已经不是那时候，甚至不是一年前那样的我们了。我知道这一点，正如我知道我们之间的关系长期以来一直在缓慢地侵蚀。我们对彼此都感到有点厌倦。有些烦恼和旧伤疤不是一封信就能抹掉的，即使这是一封在深夜里绝望地写下、在——不得不承认——喝了相当多波本威士忌的影响下写下的长信，但它毕竟怀着最诚挚的意图和希望，希望你能知道，在这个夜晚，我是如何不再需要为我们的困境寻找解释的。
We have reached this place, everything we say seems rather aggravating mindless and automatic, like something one stranger might say to another in one of the thousand circumstances where strangers are thrown together for a time, and the silence begins to grow heavy on their minds and someone has to say something.
我们走到了这一步，我们所说的一切似乎都变得极其恼人、无脑且机械，就像两个陌生人在各种被迫相处的时间里，当沉默开始在他们的心头变得沉重，其中一人必须说点什么时会说的话。
Darling, we go so long these days without having anything at all to do with each other. And the children are arriving tomorrow. And once more we'll be in the position of making all of the gestures that give them back their parents as they think their parents are. And what I wanted to say to you-- what came to me as I thought about Louise and Charles on that day so long ago, when they were young and so obviously glad of each other, and I looked at them and do it and was happy-- what came to me was that even the harsh things that happened to them, even the years of anger and silence, even the disappointment and the bitterness and the wanting not to be in the same room anymore, even all that must have been worth it for such loveliness.
亲爱的，这些日子里，我们太久没有和彼此有任何真正的交流了。孩子们明天就要到了。我们将再次陷入那种被迫去表演、去把父母的样子还原给他们的境地。而我想告诉你的是——当我想起路易丝和查尔斯在很久以前的那一天，当他们年轻且显然互为喜悦，我看着他们并因此感到快乐时——我想告诉你的是，即使是发生在他们身上的那些残酷的事情，即使是多年的愤怒和沉默，即使是失望、痛苦和不想再待在同一个房间里的愿望，即使是这一切，为了那样的美好也一定是值得的。
At least I am here, at 70 years old, hoping so. Tonight, I went back to our room again and stood gazing at you asleep, dreaming whatever you were dreaming. And I had a moment of thinking how we were always friends too, because what I wanted, finally, to say was that I remember well our own sweet times, our own old loveliness. And I would like to think that even if-- at the very beginning of our lives together-- I had somehow been shown that we would end up here with this longing to be away from each other, this feeling of being trapped together, of being tied to each other in a way that makes us wish for other times, some other place, I would have known enough to accept it all freely for the chance at that love. And if I could, I would do it all again, Marie. All of it. Even the sorrow. My sweet, my dear adversary, for everything that I remember.
至少我在这里，70岁了，依然怀着这样的希望。今晚，我再次回到我们的房间，注视着熟睡的你，梦着你梦中的一切。我有一瞬间想到我们始终也是朋友，因为我想说的最终是，我清楚地记得我们自己的甜蜜时光，我们自己往日的美好。我想即使——在我们共同生活的最初——我被预示了我们最终会走到这一步，这种渴望远离彼此、这种被困在一起的感觉、这种让我们怀念其他时间、其他地点的纽带，我也会有足够的勇气去坦然接受，为了那份爱的机会。如果可以，玛丽，我愿意重来一次。这一切。即使包括那些悲伤。我亲爱的，我亲爱的对手，为了我所记得的一切。
Richard Bausch's story-- "Letter to the Lady of the House," is in his book, Selected Stories from Richard Bausch . That's from the Modern Library. His newest book is Thanksgiving Night .
理查德·鲍什的故事——《致屋中夫人》，收录在他的书《理查德·鲍什精选故事》中。那是来自现代文库。他最新的书是《感恩节之夜》。
[MUSIC- "THE RIVER" BY BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN]
[音乐——布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀演唱的《河流》]
Coming up, a very different kind of marriage, one where they serve and protect. She serves. He protects. Or actually, maybe it's the other way around. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，是一种非常不同的婚姻，一种他们互相服务和保护的婚姻。她服务。他保护。或者其实，也许正好相反。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme. Today we wanted to bring you stories about love. But not the usual kind of love stories which try to capture that moment when your eyes meet and your heart sings and you fall, fall, fall, fall, fall. No, no no. We have a different mission. Today, as a public service, we are bringing you love stories about people who have been in the same relationship for years, stories of love years after the lightning has already struck.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨。今天我们想给你带来关于爱的故事。但不是那种试图捕捉眼神交汇、心跳加速、你坠落、坠落、坠落的常规爱情故事。不，不，不。我们有不同的使命。今天，作为一项公共服务，我们要为你带来关于那些在同一段关系中生活了多年的伴侣的爱情故事，关于那些在闪电击中多年后的爱情故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, "The Over-Protective Kind." Veronica Chater tells this story. The setting-- the Bay area suburbs. The characters-- own mother and father.
我们的节目来到了第二幕。第二幕，“过度保护型”。维罗妮卡·查特讲述了这个故事。背景——海湾地区的郊区。人物——我自己的母亲和父亲。
Recently, my parents' marriage went through a few weeks of chaos when my mom announced that she was taking a vacation. Turns out, Noreen-- her best friend of 40 years-- was inviting her to Puerta Vallarta, Mexico to spend a week in her timeshare.
最近，我父母的婚姻经历了几个星期的混乱，当时我妈宣布她要休假。原来，诺琳——她40年的闺蜜——邀请她去墨西哥的巴亚尔塔港，在她的度假屋住一周。
My parents have been married for 45 years and they've never been apart for more than a day or two. What's more, in those 45 years they've never taken a vacation. Partly because they've been raising 11 children and helping to raise 20 grandchildren, and partly because my dad's feelings about vacations go something like this--
我父母结婚45年了，他们从没分开超过一两天。更重要的是，在这45年里他们从未去度假。部分原因是因为他们抚养了11个孩子，并帮忙带大了20个孙辈，部分原因是因为我爸爸对度假的感受大概是这样的——
I detest shopping. I detest eating out. I detest motels. I detest beaches. I detest anything having to do with what most people go on vacations for. For me it's the opposite of having fun. It's a purgatory.
我讨厌购物。我讨厌在外面吃饭。我讨厌汽车旅馆。我讨厌海滩。我讨厌任何与大多数人度假目的相关的事情。对我来说，这与享受乐趣完全相反。这是一种炼狱。
Mom didn't even think of inviting him along. But as she began preparing for her trip, Dad began worrying. My Dad is something of a safety nut. He was a police officer and then a corporate security consultant. And as a result, he's the kind of guy who sees danger around every corner and is ready to defend himself and his family against any possible foe.
妈甚至没想过邀请他一起去。但随着她开始为旅行做准备，爸爸开始担心了。我爸有点安全狂。他曾经是一名警察，后来是一名企业安全顾问。结果，他就是那种在每个角落都看到危险、并时刻准备保护自己和家人免受任何潜在敌人伤害的人。
As I was growing up, whenever our birthdays came around, my brothers and sisters and I always knew the present from dad was going to be a weapon-- a hunting knife, say, or a rifle. After I was the victim of a violent crime about 10 years ago, he only got worse. He took me out to buy a gun-- a Colt thirty. 38 detective special-- and taught me how to use it. Then he wrote a book called, The Protection Formula-- Thinking Like a Cop, to teach ordinary people to be more like him. These days, when he bicycles to work each day on a busy road in the California suburbs, he carries with him a fully stocked survival kit-- ace bandages, iodine, insulating blanket and, just to be on the safe side, a 10 inch long bayonet. He'd carry a gun if he could. But as a former cop, he'd never dream of breaking California's concealed weapons law.
在我成长的过程中，每当生日到来，我和兄弟姐妹们总是知道爸爸的礼物会是武器——比如一把猎刀或一支步枪。在大约10年前我成为暴力犯罪的受害者后，他变得更严重了。他带我去买了一把枪——柯尔特.38警用特制左轮手枪——并教我如何使用。然后他写了一本书，叫《保护公式——像警察一样思考》，教普通人变得像他一样。现在，当他每天骑自行车去上班穿过加州郊区繁忙的道路时，他随身携带一个全套生存装备——弹性绷带、碘酒、保温毯，而且，为了稳妥起见，还有一把10英寸长的刺刀。如果可以，他会带枪的。但作为一名前警察，他做梦也不会去打破加州的隐藏武器法律。
Given all of this, when my mom broke the news that she was heading on vacation to a foreign country, it meant only one thing to my dad, peril.
鉴于这一切，当妈妈宣布她要独自去国外度假时，对爸爸来说意味着只有一件事，危险。
You get two quite naive women down there. And my wife still has sex appeal, so I'm concerned that's a case for worry. It isn't only that she still has sex appeal, it's the fact that there are bad people that will do things to compromise a middle aged woman. They might think she's wealthy. Who knows what a depraved person will think? You don't know, but there's plenty of them out there.
你让两个相当天真的女人去那里。而且我妻子依然很有吸引力，所以我很担心，这是一个令人担忧的情况。不仅因为她依然有吸引力，还因为那里有坏人会做些事情来伤害一个中年妇女。他们可能会以为她很富有。谁知道一个堕落的人会怎么想？你不知道，但外面那样的人多得是。
Do you think he's right to feel afraid?
你觉得他感到害怕有道理吗？
No, because of where we're going to be. When you're in a place like Puerta Vallarta, which is a resort town. And I've talked to several people that I've come in contact with who have been there and it's been fine. And we're not that naive, my goodness sakes. We're--
没有，因为我们要去的地方。当你去像巴亚尔塔港这样的地方，这是一个度假小镇。我和我接触过的几个去过那里的人谈过，那里很好。而且我们也没那么天真，天哪。我们……
Do you really think Mom's being naive to say--
你真的觉得妈妈这样说是天真吗——
Yes, yes. I think she is.
是的，是的。我觉得她是。
There we go.
这就对了。
I think there's a-- we've discussed this before-- there's a state of mind that some people do not have. They don't have a vigilance about them. They don't suspect. And that bothers me.
我觉得有一种——我们之前讨论过——有一种心态是某些人没有的。他们没有那种警惕性。他们不怀疑。这让我很烦。
Dad had plenty of ideas about what might happen to Mom in Puerta Vallarta. Someone could slip a mickey into her drink. They could copy her hotel room key and follow her back to her room. Dad stewed about this for two weeks. And then one day he announced to my mom that he had no choice. He was coming with her. It would be the only way to ensure her safety. Mom was stunned and stammered that, of course, he'd be welcome to come. And then she quickly called Noreen. This wasn't the vacation either of them had in mind. And they had to do some last minute juggling. They had to figure out sleeping arrangements. They had to buy another plane ticket. And while Mom went about shopping for swimsuits and suntan lotion,
爸爸对妈妈在巴亚尔塔港可能发生的事情有很多想法。有人可能会往她的饮料里下药。他们可能会复制她的酒店房门钥匙并跟到她的房间。爸爸为此苦恼了两个星期。然后有一天他宣布他别无选择。他要跟她一起去。这将是确保她安全的唯一方法。妈妈惊呆了，结结巴巴地说，当然欢迎他去。然后她迅速给诺琳打了电话。这不是她们中任何一个人想要的假期。她们不得不进行最后一刻的调整。她们得解决住宿安排。她们得再买一张机票。当妈妈忙着为泳装和防晒霜购物时，
Dad started preparing for the trip in his own way, by faxing a letter to the Mexican Consulate asking which weapons of self defense he could legally bring into the country. I asked Dad to read a sample from the letter.
爸爸开始以他自己的方式为旅行做准备，他给墨西哥领事馆发传真，询问他可以合法带进该国的自卫武器有哪些。我要求爸爸读一下信中的样本。
Presumably guns are not allowed there for travelers, but what about pepper spray and knives? I'm retired from law enforcement and therefore, I know intimately our state laws on bladed weapons, which are very specific as to length of blade, concealment, et cetera. And because I want to stay within the law in Mexico, I'd like to know specifics. What is the language of the laws as to blade length, concealment, folders versus fixed blades, gravity knives and so on, also, the laws on pepper spray or the like? And a final question, if we decide to rent a car and drive in the hinterland, is it possible to higher protection, for instance, off-duty policeman?
大概枪支是不允许游客携带的，但胡椒喷雾和刀具呢？我已从执法部门退休，因此，我非常清楚我们州的刀具法律，这些法律对刀片长度、隐蔽性等有非常具体的规定。而且因为我想在墨西哥遵守法律，我想知道细节。关于刀片长度、隐蔽性、折叠刀对比固定刀、重力刀等的法律用语是什么，还有，关于胡椒喷雾或类似物品的法律？还有一个问题，如果我们决定租车并开进偏远地区，是否可以雇佣保护，例如，下班后的警察？
Dad never did get a response to his letter. But he did hear from his law enforcement buddies that bringing a weapon into Mexico could land him in jail indefinitely. He began to worry that announcing his desire to enter the country armed might not have been the best way to introduce himself to the Mexican authorities. Meanwhile, my mom began worrying about how my dad was going to fare on the trip. He's a creature of habit with a nightly ritual that he follows religiously.
爸爸从没得到那封信的回复。但他确实从他的执法部门哥们儿那里听说，带武器进墨西哥可能会让他被无限期关进监狱。他开始担心，宣布他想携带武器入境可能不是向墨西哥当局介绍自己的最佳方式。与此同时，妈妈开始担心爸爸在旅途中会怎么样。他是一个习惯的产物，每天晚上都有他严格遵循的仪式。
He comes to the kitchen. He has one shot of gin and he has a beer, OK. And then he's got his little hors d'Oeuvres there. He has certain things-- radishes, carrots, onions, cheese-- he's now into gruyere. He likes the gruyere. Then he sits down and has his meal and then he has to go right to bed. And that's it. And so there's no visiting. He's got his thing. He does it. [? da, ?] duh, da, duh, da, duh, da, duh. Every night, same thing. He's so routinized, he drives you crazy.
他来到厨房。他喝一杯金酒，再喝一瓶啤酒，好吗。然后他有他的小点心。他有某些东西——小萝卜、胡萝卜、洋葱、奶酪——他现在喜欢格吕耶尔干酪。他喜欢格吕耶尔。然后他坐下来吃饭，接着他就得直接上床睡觉了。就是这样。所以没有串门。他有他的事。他做他的事。[拟声词]。每天晚上，都是一样。他太循规蹈矩了，会让你发疯的。
And does he watch a movie every night?
他每天晚上都看电影吗？
Yeah. Well not a movie, he never watches a movie. He's got six to eight pieces. He watches pieces of this, that, and the other. He's either looking for something in it-- there's a car that he saw or there's a diner, or there's a particular scene that reminds him of something, or I don't know. He's just got his little--
对。嗯不是电影，他从不看电影。他看六到八个片段。他看这儿、那儿和别处的片段。他要么是在里面找什么东西——他看到的车，或者餐馆，或者某个让他想起什么的特定场景，或者我不知道。他只是有他那一点点——
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Yeah, all that stuff.
对，所有那些东西。
For a week, my dad vacillated on his decision to go. Finally, he told Mom he'd decided to stay home, blaming his change of heart on back pain. Mom was secretly relieved. The night before she left-- as dad offered last minute instructions on how to jam the hotel door shut with a chair-- she wrote out her flight details and gave Dad a list of household chores. The next morning she was gone.
有一个星期，爸爸在去还是不去的决定上犹豫不决。最后，他告诉妈妈他决定留在家里，把改变主意的原因归结为背痛。妈妈暗自松了一口气。她离开的前一天晚上——当爸爸提出最后一刻的指示，教她如何用椅子把酒店门塞住时——她写下了她的航班细节，并给了爸爸一份家务清单。第二天早上，她走了。
Four days later, I drop in to see how Dad's getting along. When I show up, the front door is locked, something that never happens when Mom's around. I have to knock loudly, twice. When he finally opens the door, Dad is unshaven, his white hair uncombed. All the windows are closed and the curtains shut. Last night's video, Castaway , sits on the TV set. I tell Dad he looks like he's the one who's stranded on a desert island. He pretends to find the joke funny. But he can't muster a smile.
四天后，我顺道去看看爸爸过得怎么样。我出现时，前门是锁着的，这在妈妈在场时从没发生过。我不得不大声敲门，敲了两次。当他终于打开门时，爸爸没刮胡子，白发没梳。所有的窗户都关着，窗帘也拉上了。昨晚的录像带，《荒岛余生》，摆在电视机上。我告诉爸爸他看起来就像那个被困在荒岛上的人。他假装觉得这个笑话很有趣。但他挤不出一个笑容。
So, OK, so we go 0-1-1.
所以，好吧，我们去0-1-1。
I suggest we call Mom to check up on her.
我建议我们打电话给妈妈检查一下她。
Well, we cannot believe the humidity here, the heat. We've just had to stay in the hotel the whole time. It's dirty out there, just dirty.
嗯，我们简直不敢相信这里的湿度，这热度。我们只能一直待在酒店。外面很脏，简直脏死了。
You had to stay in the hotel?
你们不得不待在酒店？
Yeah, we've just had to stay in here, because we can't stand the heat.
对，我们只能待在这里，因为我们受不了这热度。
Oh my gosh. It really makes me feel better.
天哪。这真的让我感觉好多了。
It makes you feel better?
它让你感觉好多了？
Yeah, I'm almost to the point of being in a full depression here with you being away.
对，因为你离开，我快要陷入完全的抑郁了。
Mom knows just the words that will get Dad's attention. Heat, dirt, thieves, danger all around.
妈妈知道哪些词能引起爸爸的注意。热度、肮脏、小偷、四处的危险。
Well, we walked by some people. And Noreen and I, we were just hanging on to our purses. We thought, oh my gosh, Lyle was right. He should have come, for pete's sake. What are we in here? This is ridiculous. I don't know. But anyways--
嗯，我们走过一些人旁边。我和诺琳，我们一直在抓着我们的钱包。我们心想，天哪，莱尔是对的。他真该来的。我们在这是干嘛呢？这简直荒谬。我不知道。但无论如何——
Haven't you done any shopping or--
你们还没去购物或者——
How can you shop? You can't even breathe out there.
怎么购物？外面连气都透不过来。
Dad leans back in his chair. He's beaming. He looks genuinely pleased that he was right about everything, that Mom is stuck in her hotel room having no fun at all. Finally, when she knows Dad is all worked up, she drops the bomb.
爸爸靠回他的椅子上。他满面红光。他看起来真心高兴自己对一切都判断正确，妈妈被困在酒店房间里根本没有享受到任何乐趣。最后，当她知道爸爸已经完全上火时，她扔下了一枚炸弹。
OK, now you want the real scoop now, are you ready?
好吧，现在你想要真正的猛料了，准备好了吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK. It's fabulous, absolutely fabulous.
好吧。这太棒了，绝对太棒了。
Oh, now I'm getting depressed again.
哦，现在我又开始抑郁了。
I'm sorry, but I need to tell the truth here. Oh my gosh. In fact, we weren't here because we were laying by the pool.
对不起，但我得说实话。天哪。事实上，我们不在这里是因为我们躺在游泳池边。
The trip was just as they'd imagined it would be. No, better. The people were the friendliest she'd ever met. She and Noreen were buying tacos from street vendors, bartering with the local merchants, and attending mass in a Mexican church. You could hear in her voice that she was having the time of her life. And this was even before we saw the pictures of the young waiter pouring tequila and grenadine down her throat at dinner one night.
旅行正如她们想象的那样。不，更好。人们是她见过的最友善的。她和诺琳从街头小贩那买塔科，与当地商人讨价还价，在墨西哥教堂参加弥撒。你可以从她的声音听出她在享受人生中最美好的时光。这甚至是在我们看到那些年轻服务员在晚餐时把龙舌兰酒和红石榴糖浆倒进她喉咙的照片之前。
As Mom goes on, Dad's face slowly sinks into a frown. He looks disappointed and confused. Not a single bad thing happened? It was all good. He waits for Mom's effervescence to run out of fizz. And when it doesn't, he jumps in at the first opportunity.
随着妈妈不断地讲，爸爸的脸慢慢沉了下来。他看起来既失望又困惑。没发生一件坏事？一切都好？他等着妈妈的活力耗尽。当没耗尽时，他第一时间插了进来。
Let me interrupt. I couldn't find the freezer key.
让我打断一下。我找不到冰箱钥匙了。
It's hanging above the washer. I showed you.
它挂在洗衣机上面。我给你看过。
OK. I'll look. And I couldn't find the checkbook.
好吧。我会找找。而且我找不到支票簿。
Then, when Mom asks Dad how he's doing, he gives her all the grisly details of the lousy time he's been having in her absence.
然后，当妈妈问爸爸过得怎么样时，他向她诉说了她在缺席期间他所过的糟糕日子。
Those packaged food things you bought me are awful.
你买给我的那些包装食品太难吃了。
You're kidding.
你开玩笑吧。
Our best meal since you've been gone has been Jack-in-the-Box.
你离开后我们吃得最好的一顿是杰克盒子快餐（Jack-in-the-Box）。
Did you put those in the oven?
你把它们放进烤箱了吗？
Yeah, I cooked them the way--
对，我像——
Oven or the microwave?
烤箱还是微波炉？
No, in the microwave.
不，用微波炉。
No, oven is always better for those things.
不，烤箱做那些东西总会更好吃。
Well, it's too late.
好吧，太晚了。
Those were expensive, those should be really good, Lyle.
那些很贵，那些应该非常好吃的，莱尔。
Well, they weren't.
嗯，并没有。
When Dad hangs up the phone, he sinks further into self pity. All these years he'd been living under the misconception that he was the one in charge, the man with the badge-- worried and over-protective and laying down the rules. But in fact, she is the one who takes care of him. Without Mom at home to look after him, Dad was defenseless.
当爸爸挂断电话时，他陷入了更深的自怜。这些年来，他一直生活在误解中，认为自己是当家作主的人，那个戴徽章的人——担心、过度保护、制定规则。但事实上，是她在照顾他。家里没有妈妈照顾他，爸爸简直手足无措。
I want her to go and have a good time. It isn't that. It's just that I'm so used to having her presence here. It's incredible. It's physical. You can't see it coming. All of a sudden she's gone, she's not here, there is a different aura in the house.
我希望她去玩得开心。不是那样的。只是我太习惯她在这里的存在了。这太不可思议了。它是物质性的。你无法预见它的到来。突然她走了，她不在这里，家里就有一种完全不同的气场。
What does the house feel like?
家里感觉怎么样？
Cold. She really is-- she has a radiance about her. And she brightens things and that's gone.
冷。她真的——她有一种光芒。她点亮了一切，而那光芒消失了。
My mom survived the trip and my dad did too. And he even found his way to the right location at the airport to pick up mom. True, he did arrive more than an hour late. Mom let him know she wasn't too happy about that. And once she got home, she reprimanded him for being a hopeless housekeeper and a terrible gardener. But Mom could have scolded Dad all she liked, he was enjoying every minute of it. You could see it in his face as she lined up the sliced radishes, counted out the correct number of olives, and made his salad just the way he likes it.
妈妈度过了这次旅行，爸爸也挺过来了。他甚至找到了去机场接妈妈的正确位置。诚然，他确实晚到了一个多小时。妈妈让他知道她对此并不太高兴。回到家后，她责备他是一个没用的管家和糟糕的园丁。但妈妈想怎么责备爸爸都行，他却在享受其中的每一分钟。当她排列起切好的萝卜，数出正确的橄榄个数，并照他喜欢的方式为他做沙拉时，你可以从他的脸上看出来。
Veronica Chater in northern California.
北加州的维罗妮卡·查特。
[MUSIC- "SOMEONE TO WATCH OVER ME" BY RICKI LEE JONES]
[音乐——瑞奇·李·琼斯演唱的《有人守护我》]
Well, we end our program today, about what love is like long after the moment you fall in love, with this story about monogamy itself, from Ian Brown.
嗯，我们今天以伊恩·布朗关于一夫一妻制本身的这个故事结束我们的节目，关于坠入爱河很久之后的生活是什么样子。
There's a couple across my street who make love in their living room. I hear them in the evening when I walk after dinner. From the sidewalk, I can see cream walls, a mantle draped in animal hides, African carvings. The woman makes most of the noise-- mid-range ohs, a second apart, dropping like small crystal cups out of the open French windows of their flat. Passion and disregard for the neighbors, a tremendous combination. The air stops moving around me.
街对面有一对夫妻在客厅里做爱。晚饭后散步时我常能听到。从人行道看过去，我能看到米色的墙壁，盖着动物皮毛的壁炉架，非洲雕刻。女人发出的声音最大——中音的“啊”，隔一秒一声，像小小的水晶杯从他们公寓敞开的法式窗户掉落。激情加上对邻居的无视，真是极好的结合。周围的空气似乎都静止了。
Is their sex better than my own? I wonder what she looks like when she's moaning. Does she love him, presuming it's a him, which I always do? Or is she there just for the sex? I can never decide which would be more exciting. I imagine she's in her 30s and that she has dark hair, an ordinary woman with ordinary chores whose passion is nonetheless excitingly unsuppressible in the evening.
他们的性生活比我的更好吗？我好奇她呻吟时是什么样子。她爱他吗——假设是“他”，我总是这么想。还是她只是为了性？我永远无法决定哪种情况更令人兴奋。我想象她30出头，留着黑发，一个有着平凡家务的平凡女人，但她的激情却在夜晚兴奋地无法抑制。
But which woman is it? Is the moaner the doctor who just had a baby, only now returning to sex? The Mexican girl who works out all the time at the gym? Or the Chinese caterer, the woman who drives the Volvo with Ohio license plates?
但到底是哪个女人？这个呻吟的人是刚生完孩子、才恢复性生活的医生吗？是健身房里总是在锻炼的墨西哥女孩吗？还是开着俄亥俄州牌照沃尔沃的中国餐饮承办商？
Her cries never last more than half a block. Walking back to my house, I usually have a few bent, embarrassed thoughts. I think, you're a 39-year-old married man who stands in front of his house listening to an unseen couple make love. You're sick. But I keep stepping out there, hoping to hear that little duet.
她的叫声从不会持续超过半个街区。走回我的房子，我通常会产生一些扭曲、尴尬的想法。我想，你是个39岁的已婚男人，站在自己家门口听一对看不见的夫妇做爱。你有病。但我还是不断地走出去，希望能听到那段小小的二重奏。
My wife wants to have a baby. And it's not just talk or a plan she inherited at birth or the fantasizing she used to practice with the girlfriends-- well, I want to have four-- no, this is different, more insistent.
我妻子想要个孩子。这不仅仅是聊天，或者是她出生时继承的计划，也不是她过去和女朋友们练习的幻想——“好吧，我想生四个”——不，这不一样，更加迫切。
"When would you like to start?" she said again this morning, third time in a week, as we read the newspaper over breakfast. The sun was already bearing down furiously at half past eight in the God damn morning. I could hear the buzz of a weed whacker next door.
“你想什么时候开始？”她今天早上又说了一遍，这周第三次了，我们在早餐时读着报纸。早上八点半，该死的阳光已经在猛烈地照射着。我能听到隔壁割草机的嗡嗡声。
"Anytime you like," I said, not taking my eyes off the paper. I didn't want to encourage her because the truth is this. Some days I'm for it. But when I'm not for it, I'm really not for it.
“任何时候，随你喜欢，”我说，没有把目光从报纸上移开。我不想鼓励她，因为事实是这样的：有些日子我支持，但当我不支持的时候，我是真的不支持。
My wife's body has changed. Her body, overtaken by hormonal committee, is telling her to get on with its grandest physical purpose. I can see it in the slight, post-marital widening of her hips-- no less sexy than the originals, but still wider-- when she lilts away from the bed at night to perform her ablutions. I can see it in her taste in clothes. She doesn't go any more for the sprayed-on Lycra skirts I used to buy her. Even in her sexual habits, she has less interest in sex than she used to. She wants to make love now for keeps. Pause here for sadness.
我妻子的身体变了。她的身体被荷尔蒙委员会接管，正在告诉她去完成它最宏大的身体目的。我可以从她婚后稍微变宽的臀部看到——虽然不如原来的性感，但依然更宽了——当她晚上摇曳着离开床去洗漱时。我可以在她对衣服的品味中看到。她不再追求我以前为她买的紧身莱卡裙子了。即使在性习惯上，她对性的兴趣也比过去少了。她现在想认真地做爱。此处暂停，怀念一下。
Last week, as if by magic, two baby books appeared in the pile on the floor on her side of the bed. At the bottom of the pile, but there they were. I walked into the bedroom, saw them like a promise I made long ago and had to leave the house. I went to a matinee.
上周，仿佛魔法一样，两本育儿书出现在她床边地板的堆叠物里。在最下面，但它们确实在那儿。我走进卧室，看到它们就像我很久以前许下的承诺，必须离开房子。我去看了一场日间场电影。
When did all that happen? I can't remember anything. The dates of our courtship, the countless touching things she claims I said, they're at best a blur to me, a fog of declarations. One day, I was living my comfortable life and the next she was living with me. On a bad day, it makes me nervous to remember all this. On a bad day, when I think about the slow gelling of our togetherness-- it's gathering weight and formality-- the muscle around my heart closes in and my breath comes short and I start to panic.
这一切是什么时候发生的？我不记得任何事了。我们求爱的时间，她声称我说的无数感人的话，对我来说充其量是一片模糊，是一团宣言的迷雾。有一天，我还在过着舒适的生活，第二天她就和我住在一起了。在糟糕的日子里，回忆这一切让我感到紧张。在糟糕的日子里，当我想起我们在一起的过程缓慢地凝聚——聚集着重量和形式——我心脏周围的肌肉就收紧，呼吸变得急促，我开始恐慌。
One day she and I were dating, and then we were living together, and then we bought a house, and then we married, and then she wanted to have a baby-- an escalator of commitments on to which I had apparently stepped. My friends were astonished. They said I wasn't the type to marry. A few of them had made bets against it. I told them I wanted to find out what lay on the other side of boredom. I stole that line from an old girlfriend. I thought I was an adventurer. And yet, here I stand in a well-trimmed front yard, surrounded by neighbors and swing sets and sport utility vehicles-- the movable monuments of domesticity-- listening to a couple copulate. And across the yards, I see another man looking warily back at me, doing exactly the same thing.
有一天她和我还在约会，然后我们同居了，然后我们买了房，然后我们结婚了，然后她想生个孩子——这是一条我显然已经踏上去的承诺自动扶梯。我的朋友们很惊讶。他们说我不是结婚的料。他们中有些人还打了赌说不会。我告诉他们我想看看无聊的另一面是什么。我从一个老女友那里偷了那句话。我以为我是个冒险家。然而，我站在这里，在一个修剪整齐的前院里，被邻居、秋千和运动型多用途车环绕——那是家庭生活的移动纪念碑——听着一对夫妇交媾。而在院子对面，我看到另一个男人警惕地看着我，做着完全一样的事情。
Just because I'm married now, and practicing what's known as monogamy, doesn't mean I don't think about other women because I do. I still conjure up women from my past. And I still ask myself the question. You know the question. Every man does. Women have their own version of it. The question is the question you ask yourself every time you see a woman on the street-- every single time, no matter who she is, how old she is, no matter how attractive she is or isn't. And the question is, would I sleep with her? Or her? Or how about her?
仅仅因为我现在结婚了，并且在实践所谓的一夫一妻制，并不意味着我不去想别的女人，因为我确实在想。我仍然会幻想起过去的女人。我仍然在问自己那个问题。你知道那个问题。每个男人都会。女人也有她们自己的版本。这个问题就是你每次在街上看到一个女人时都会问自己的问题——每一次，无论她是谁，多大年纪，无论她是否有吸引力。这个问题是，我会和她睡觉吗？或者她？或者她怎么样？
Not, will I sleep with her? Or, how can I sleep with her? Or even, could I sleep with her? The question is, would I? But even though I always ask the question, I don't act on it because I'm trying to be monogamous. That's why monogamy has such a bad reputation. It's boring. Monogamy is the habit of not acting on what you want. I even hate the word itself. It sounds so staid, so bourgeois. Monogamy, like a board game, the approximation of excitement.
不是，我会和她睡觉吗？或者，我该怎么和她睡觉？甚至，我可以和她睡觉吗？这个问题是，我会吗？但尽管我总是问这个问题，我没有行动，因为我在努力维持一夫一妻制。这就是为什么一夫一妻制名声这么差。它很无聊。一夫一妻制是那种“不去实践你欲望”的习惯。我甚至讨厌这个词本身。它听起来太死板，太资产阶级了。一夫一妻制，就像一种棋盘游戏，对兴奋的模仿。
Sometimes, of course, I hear about open marriages. Jung had one, Sartre had won, Henry Miller, Dickens, Freud. I hear about open marriages, and they seem like some fabulous, exotic city that I've always wanted to visit but never seem to get to. Istanbul, open marriages are like Istanbul. Some ancient, mysterious place where there are minarets and strange music, where one entire civilization suddenly ends and a whole new stranger one begins, a whole new religion even, the mysterious east. I've always wanted to go to Istanbul.
有时，当然，我听说过开放式婚姻。荣格有一个，萨特有一个，亨利·米勒、狄更斯、弗洛伊德。我听说过开放式婚姻，它们看起来像某个我一直想去但似乎从未去过的美妙异国城市。伊斯坦布尔，开放式婚姻就像伊斯坦布尔。某个古老、神秘的地方，有宣礼塔和奇怪的音乐，整个文明突然终结，一个全新的、更陌生的文明随之开始，甚至是一个全新的宗教，神秘的东方。我一直想去伊斯坦布尔。
Like most couples, my wife and I sometimes talk about open marriages. Well, I say we talk about it. It'd be more accurate to say that the subject comes up and immediately lies down again. We'll be lying in bed in the dark and talking about our lives-- about what we like and what we miss-- in that quiet, pleasant way you do when you're trying to be monogamous.
像大多数夫妻一样，我和我妻子有时也会谈论开放式婚姻。好吧，我说我们谈论它。更准确地说，是这个话题提出来后，立即又躺下去了。我们会躺在黑暗的床上谈论我们的生活——谈论我们喜欢的和我们错过的——以那种在努力维持一夫一妻制时那种安静、愉快的方式。
Then my wife will say in the dark, "You know, if you ever have sex with someone else, some passing fling, I don't want you to tell me about it."
然后我妻子会在黑暗中说：“你知道，如果你哪天和别人发生了性关系，某种短暂的艳遇，我不希望你告诉我。”
And I say, "Really?" I say, really, because I don't know what else to say. If I say, "OK honey, that's fine with me."
我说：“真的吗？”我说“真的吗”，因为我不知道还能说什么。如果我说，“好的亲爱的，我没问题。”
She'll say, "What, are you thinking about it?"
她会说：“怎么，你在考虑这件事吗？”
Then I'll have to say, "Of course not," even if I am. So I say, "Really?" Or I'll say something non-committal like, "Don't worry."
那我就得说：“当然没有，”即使我真的有。所以我说：“真的吗？”或者我会说些不置可否的话，比如，“别担心。”
Whatever I say, a few minutes go by. And then she always says, still in the dark, "But I don't want you to sleep with someone else anyway. OK?"
无论我说什么，几分钟过去了。然后她总会说，依然是在黑暗中，“但无论如何我不希望你和别人睡觉。好吗？”
And I say, "OK." That's the kind of conversation you have when you agree to be monogamous.
我说：“好。”这就是当你同意维持一夫一妻制时会有的那种对话。
I don't want to sleep with anyone else. Or to be more exact, I'd like to, but I really don't have the constitution for infidelity or for an open marriage or for the guilt. Monogamy may be boring, but the alternatives take up a lot more time and energy. I don't pretend it has anything to do with moral standards. In fact, I suspect it comes down to something my wife once said to me. We were having one of our conversational minuets in the dark, one of our gentle but ever so delicate chats about faithfulness, when my wife said that the only thing she missed as a monogamous woman-- at least, I assume she was speaking as a monogamous women-- was newness, new bodies, new hands, new sex. I said I knew what she meant.
我不希望和任何人睡觉。或者更准确地说，我想，但我真的没有不忠的体质，也没有开放式婚姻或负罪感的体质。一夫一妻制可能很无聊，但替代方案需要花费更多的时间和精力。我不假装这与道德标准有任何关系。事实上，我怀疑这归结为我妻子曾经对我所说的一句话。我们在黑暗中进行着对话小步舞曲，关于忠诚的那种温柔但极其微妙的聊天，当时我妻子说，作为一个一夫一妻制的女人——至少，我假设她是以一夫一妻制女人的身份说话——她唯一错过的是新鲜感，新的身体，新的手，新的性。我说我知道她的意思。
And I said, "But isn't that kind of sad? I mean, if you go through your whole life-- 20, 30, 40, 60 years of marriage-- without ever straying, you do that, you never get to know what it's like to be unfaithful. You never get to know what it feels like to be emotionally illegal. And that's an important feeling, one of the great human themes, after all, a whole constellation of humanity you'll never know.
我说：“但这难道不有点可悲吗？我是说，如果你一辈子——20、30、40、60年的婚姻——从不出轨，你就做到了，你永远无法了解不忠是什么感觉。你永远无法知道被感情定性为非法是什么感觉。而那毕竟是一个重要的人类主题，那是你永远无法了解的一整个人类星群。”
My wife is quiet for a long time. I could hear the fridge downstairs, and in the street light coming through the curtains, I could just see her outline. And I thought to myself, I've spent a long time in this bed.
我妻子沉默了很久。我能听到楼下冰箱的声音，在透过窗帘射进来的街灯光下，我只能看到她的轮廓。我心想，我在床上待了很久。
"Yes," my wife said then, "That's true. But if you do sleep around, you'll never know what it's like to be faithful to one person your whole life, which might also be an important constellation of humanity." There was just a touch of sarcasm in her voice. And then it was my turn to lie in the dark for a long time.
“是的，”我妻子当时说，“那是真的。但如果你到处睡，你永远不会知道对一个人忠诚一辈子是什么感觉，那可能也是一个人性星群的重要组成部分。”她的声音里带着一丝讽刺。然后轮到我在黑暗中躺很久了。
I'd never considered monogamy as an adventure. I thought it was, well, domestic travel, where no international borders are crossed. But monogamy is an adventure, and in some ways, a more mysterious one than open marriage. Because trying to be faithful to one person is a trip that takes time. And you never really know if you're getting close or if you've reached the destination. You never really know when you've arrived.
我从未把一夫一妻制当作一种冒险。我以为那是，好吧，国内旅行，不需要跨越国界的旅行。但一夫一妻制是一场冒险，在某些方面，比开放式婚姻更神秘。因为尝试对一个人忠诚是一趟耗时的旅程。你永远不知道自己是否在靠近，或者是否已经到达了终点。你永远不知道你何时到达。
For my generation, the first one that assumed free love for both sexes was a birth right, for us, monogamy is the last sexual mystery on earth, the great unknown. We've tried everything else. It's certainly a different kind of trip than open marriage, which has lots of stops along the way, though most of them are the same. Maybe that's the problem with open marriage, not many surprises. It's titillating, but not very mysterious. Maybe that's why hearing about open marriages always makes me a little sad, why there's always a whiff of defeat about them.
对于我们这一代人来说，这是第一代假设男女双方自由恋爱是与生俱来的权利的人，对我们来说，一夫一妻制是地球上最后的性之谜，伟大的未知。我们尝试过其他一切了。这当然与开放式婚姻有着不同的旅程，开放式婚姻沿途有很多停靠点，尽管大多数都是一样的。也许这就是开放式婚姻的问题，惊喜不多。它很刺激，但不怎么神秘。也许这就是为什么听说开放式婚姻总是让我感到有点悲伤，为什么它总有一股失败的气息。
I lay there in the dark beside my wife thinking about all this, as I say, for a long time. I thought about that dream of hers, to be faithful her whole life. I thought, it's a sweet dream, almost like an ideal. And I knew I didn't want to be the one to prove to her that it couldn't come true. It scared me too, all that responsibility, because it's not such a wise thing to promise.
我躺在黑暗中，就在妻子身边思考着这一切，正如我所说的，想了很久。我想到了她的那个梦，一辈子只忠诚于一个人。我想，这是一个甜蜜的梦，几乎像是一个理想。我知道我不想成为那个向她证明这无法实现的人。这也让我害怕，所有那些责任，因为这并不是一个明智的承诺。
Anyway, I'm trying to be monogamous. Maybe not even for myself, maybe I'm just doing it for her. Is that so unusual? Maybe if I do it for her long enough, I'll start to do it for me as well. It's not that I don't want to go to Istanbul anymore, I really want to. In fact, I think about Istanbul all the time, if only to remind myself that it's still there. It's just that, there's this other place I want to get to first, a little town that, for the longest time, I never even knew was there.
无论如何，我在努力维持一夫一妻制。也许甚至不是为了我自己，也许我只是为了她。这很罕见吗？也许如果我为她坚持得足够久，我会开始为我自己也这样做。不是说我不再想去伊斯坦布尔了，我真的很想去。事实上，我一直都在想伊斯坦布尔，哪怕只是提醒自己它依然在那里。只是，还有另一个地方我想先去，一个小镇，很长一段时间以来，我甚至不知道它的存在。
Ian Brown is the host of Talking Books on CBC Radio, and the anchor for two TV shows on TV Ontario. Part of his comments are from his book, Man Medium Rare .
伊恩·布朗是加拿大广播公司（CBC）《谈谈书》（Talking Books）节目的主持人，也是安大略省电视网两档电视节目的主播。他的部分评论摘自他的书《男人，三分熟》（Man Medium Rare）。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior Editor for this show, Paul Tough. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef.
好了，我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。本节目的高级编辑保罗·塔夫。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。制作助理塞斯·林德和艾米丽·优素福。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast. Free. www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们每周的免费播客。免费的。www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia. And you know, you would think a job like his-- running a public radio station-- would just be fun, fun, fun.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，你会觉得像他这样——经营一家公共广播电台——的工作一定充满乐趣。
For me it's the opposite of having fun. It's a purgatory.
对我来说，这与享受乐趣完全相反。这是一种炼狱。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
P R I, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。